[Music]
[Applause]
I was walking in the street
we heard a phone call we
turned around we saw people
running from right to left and after 5 6
minutes after me I saw that  there are
people because I already know who
work at the hairdressing salon we
entered the salon
and there are three injured people in the salon
after I was asked to call the
fire department it's me who is calling it  it was I
who made the police to say that there are
injured
[Music] to
interest him was already known to the
legal services since he has
both backgrounds even if these
background searches continue with I do not tell
you  communication only from what
I know following my transport to
the scene
[Music]